[موسيقى]
قابلنا في الاهوار نشره البيئي
حياته يجمع معلومات وابحاث عن الاهوار
وكيفيه المحافظه عليها خاصه بعد دمها الى
رائحه التراث العالمي من قبل اليونسكو
لقد القت موضوعات المياه بظلالها على
الوضع العام في
العراقيه فالاوار العراقيه اكثر المناطق
هشاشه بتغير المناخ وبتاثيره الجفاف
الحالي الذي يضربها منذ عام تقريبا على
وجه التحديد
انخفضت اطلاقات المائيه كثيره
والفرات لكن للاسف الشديد هذا العام
انخفض الاغمار الى حدود كبيره لا تتجاوز
السابعه بالمئه
هو هذا يعني انه هواره ينقهر الحويزه انه
بحيره مهمه كبحيره ام النعاج
اليوم نحن في الاغوار الوسطى والبركه
البغداديه جفت جفاف كامل بحيث فقد مربي
الجاموس من 20 الى
33% من قطعانهم